the past does not equal the future just
because something didn't work out for
you before just because you tried
something and failed at it it doesn't
mean that you won't have success in the
future a lot of people get stuck in the
trap thinking that they only have one
shot you've only got one shot that try
something if it doesn't work out that's
it you have as many shots as you want
this is your life the only person sets
the rules is you so how many shots do
you want to take I got a great email
from one of my newsletter readers I knew
Rod Carew didn't say hi I've been have
been the followers of yours for many
years I admire the inspiration you bring
entrepreneurs like me I've had two
failed businesses behind me these
businesses did not take off for various
reasons now I want to start a new
business but with two failed ventures
behind me I'm feeling a little skeptical
to start can you please give me some
advice how to go about it as your advice
is something I hold in very high esteem
thanks I know reg this is a great
question and one I think a lot of people
go through you try something it doesn't
work out and then you think you're a
total failure and you don't want to try
again if you look at famous
entrepreneurs look at any successful
entrepreneur they had tons of failure
early on in their lives they had failure
had to fail to feel it before they hit
it look at it look at your favorite
famous entrepreneur whoever it is
wherever you look up to the most and
look at how they got started and you'll
see tons of failures before they
eventually hit it so my story before I
had Redis off which is my software
company I tried a whole bunch of
different ventures and I remember one I
was maybe 16 years old and I wanted to
start this online business you know the
online was just taking off and I had a
buddy of mine who's gonna be my partner
and we had one computer in the house and
he bunked over he stayed over for the
summer and we worked crazy hours because
we had to share this one computer and he
would work for three hours while I slept
and then he'd wake me up and I'd worked
with three hours while he slept and we
did this shift work so we could get as
much time in the computer as possible
and the business didn't work out right I
thought it's a good idea maybe we're
of our time whatever it didn't work out
so what do I do with that do I then say
I sixteen my life is over
you know so I failed at my first
business and now nothing's ever gonna
work out again no right that's silly I'm
not gonna go back and now go get a job
and let this corporate life because I
tried one thing and didn't work out but
that's that's what happens to a lot of
people I know it's scary and you start
to doubt yourself and and the doubt the
doubts always there okay you look at
entrepreneurs and it's a dirty little
secret that people always think that
they have the answer right you look at
successful entrepreneurs but there's
constant doubt there's constant doubt
especially in the early stages and you
think about giving up and quitting and
going back to a safe stable job so the
fear is there but it doesn't mean that
you don't take action
you look fear in the eyes and you go
forward because again this is your life
right what are you doing I know it's
hard I know it can be frustrating
especially when you've seen a couple
failures and and that doubt creeps in
but you have to remember why you're
doing this
okay hopefully you have a strong why
right you're trying to change people's
lives for the better somehow and
hopefully you've learned something from
those past failures if you go in and try
to do the exact same thing you're doing
before then you're probably gonna fail
but if you've learned some things if
you've grown stronger if you've picked
up skills if you're gonna try a new
approach if you're passionate about this
business that you're going into if you
know what's gonna help a lot of people
then chances are you'll be successful so
if you have a dream if you really want
this badly don't give up just because
you failed in the past because everybody
fails the difference is the people who
become successful are the ones who get
up off the ground and try again and try
again and try again until they hit it
that's what successful entrepreneurs do
believe so those are you watching I love
the hero you have to think leave a
comment underneath
click on the link to support me in the
description if you want like this video
click my face subscribe to the channel
thank you so much I'll see you soon